so what I want to do today is just like
Monday
um it's going to be sort of like we're
still going to be thinking about the dot
product today which we began on Monday
um or rather we continued on Monday
because everything we looked at in the
dot product in 3D comes from our
understanding of the dot product in 2D
and we looked at the interesting
parallel between those
um pun not intended but not avoided
either anyway
I wanted to bring you back to the
syllabus because I think it's so helpful
to always draw you back to what's going
on here so just to refresh your memory
right this is what we looked at last
time do you recall I was explaining why
I was teaching you this um skill a ratio
division internal external all that
funny stuff even though ratio division
isn't like explicitly named anywhere in
the syllabus as you're looking at right
now however it's just a really great way
to uh experience and encounter and use
the particular skills and knowledge that
the syllabus does want us to learn
particularly all this three-dimensional
Vector arithmetic so this is if you have
a look just up the top here this is um
the structure of the syllabus is that
within um a topic like 3D vectors so
that's the V in V 1.1 there are like
little sub sections as well so this was
just in the introduction we've actually
already if I go over the page we've
already gone into
um V 1.2 further our operations with
three-dimensional vectors I just didn't
tell you that we were so for example
Define calculate and use the magnitude
of a vector so you can see do you
remember this is from that Pythagoras
result right it's just Pythagoras in
three dimensions we haven't spoken
explicitly that much about it but what's
going on here you can say if you've got
a non-zero Vector called U so any Vector
except for the zero Vector so it's going
somewhere so long as it's facing in any
direction what you can do is you can
take that well let's use this you can
take that Vector right and you just have
to divide by the magnitude that thing
that we got just here also known as its
length and what you'll get is a unit
Vector version of that Vector so instead
of it being of any arbitrary size it
will be one unit and will be facing in
whichever direction you started with so
all you're doing is having a division by
the appropriate scalar but appropriate
number okay
uh last lesson you saw just moving on
what we did was we defined the um the
dot product of two vectors in three
dimensions and kind of what we're on to
now is this idea of using the dot
product and this is often the way I
don't know if you've noticed this um
about maths but we kind of often teach
you a thing and then we say okay this is
like a new tool in your toolbox what can
we do with this tool what kinds of cool
problems can we solve with it and that's
kind of what we're going to be having a
look at today we're actually going to
continue it on Friday as well just
cheekily I will also make reference
since it's here on the page just have a
look at this uh part down the bottom
here it says
um extend the formula and then you've
got U dot V equals and you'll recognize
this from last lesson do you remember
this so this is the the polar formula
um for a DOT product and we called it
polar because it's got magnitude and
Direction built into it so here's the
magnitude part and then here's the
direction part right
um the difference is that the direction
is the angle between the two vectors if
we if we put them tail to tail okay and
it's a very cheeky kind of word there
but it says extend uh it's another way
of saying hey the formula works exactly
the way it worked in three dimensions as
it did in two Dimensions so that's why
it's the same formula okay so we're
going to jump right off of that and
we're going to say well what what can we
do with this thing okay there's a lot of
different things you can do with the dot
product that's that's why we learn it
but first let's just jot down in our
notes so if you want to make the heading
using the dot product
uh let's recall right we've got our two
definitions for the dot product
there's the component definition and
then there is also the polar definition
we saw before so this the polar
definition is the one I want to focus on
today so you guys told me before it's
the magnitude of each of the two um
uh vectors that you've got multiplied by
COS of the angle between the two vectors
okay just as a very very minor Point
um as well when I was asking you about
this on Monday one of the things we kind
of snuck in was this language is
absolute value do you remember that
now that's totally fine like if you say
absolute value
um like I knew what you were talking
about like of course that that makes
sense right however I I kind of want to
expand on that that notation that the
absolute value idea really makes sense
when you're just thinking about
um
scalar numbers and when you're thinking
about them just in real terms so you're
just taking the positive value that's
the absolute part of absolute value but
you know and hopefully you've heard me
say it actually
um I'm using the word magnitude often
because that's probably a more sensible
word to use in this context right it's
not like you take a vector and then just
take the positive part that's what is
the positive part of a vector like which
direction are you facing in right
magnitude really is getting at what's
the size of it okay one more by the way
there's another word do you guys
remember there's another m word from
complex numbers that we use when we have
the same notation what was that
yeah very good so modulus like it's
funny we use the same notation for for
three fairly different sounding words
but again these are actually connected
right magnitude and modulus in
particular are connected because they're
the distance from one fixed Point namely
the origin in the case of complex
numbers right so when you're on the
Argan diagram these all fit together but
what I want to encourage you to do is uh
given the different contexts I want you
to try and use the most appropriate word
or phrase for it we're in vectors so
we're thinking about the magnitudes or
the sizes of vectors
okay now uh sorry that was a bit of an
aside what I want to do is I want you to
notice that uh just like with the cosign
rule um do you remember I think Sean you
were the one who mentioned that
um we might memorize the cosine rule uh
in Pythagoras mode right so that's this
you don't have to jot it down again
because I know you you guys know it this
is the Pythagoras mode version of the
cosine rule right and what you've got
there is that c squared C little C the
side
um the side that would have been the
hypotenuse if it was a right angled
triangle that's the subject so this
formula is geared towards finding uh
what that length is but what you saw
before we could just rearrange this make
cause Theta or cos C rather the subject
and then the same formula is now geared
up to find the angle right now I hope
you notice we can do exactly the same
thing with the dot product can you see
we've got cos Theta again if we make
that the subject then we can Gear Up The
Dot product for finding angles or
understanding angle relationships so
let's just quickly jot that down right
if I make cos Theta the subject I'm just
dividing both sides by what
um the magnitudes yeah fantastic but and
you um you paid attention right yes they
are the magnitudes of A and B
um the product of the magnitudes I guess
we would say right so if you divide
through by both sides then you've got
cos Theta so
um the thing on the right hand side you
can see it's independent of theta we can
work all of that out just with the
components um the X and the Y and the Z
components right